hello there guys so ahsoka tano played
by rosario dawson
just got confirmed on the official
german disney plus
account i'll play the clip for you now
from the mandalorian rosario
so guys this is huge news because for
many months now
ahsoka tano has been rumored and we have
finally got the official word
that she'll be indeed in season two of
the mandalorian rosaria dawson was
actually
hinting at her involvement for a very
long time now in past
interviews and stuff but you know it's
just great to finally get an official
word that
she'll be indeed in season two of the
mandalorian and also
timothy overhand was actually confirmed
as well and
he was rumored for a while to be um
wearing boba fett's armor in season two
so him being confirmed now brings back
to a previous theory
why i reckon we see an episode where the
mandalorian will help retrieve boba
fett's armor and give it back to him cuz
you know boba fett was also confirmed
for season two
because an agency actually confirmed
morrison's involvement so that pretty
much confirms boba fett unless they're
referring to rex
but rumors suggest that this is for boba
fett being away back to associate um i
actually
wonder what will her role be will it be
a big role a small
role or just a cameo honestly i think
it'll be more than a cameo because she
has been so rumored for a long time
so i don't think it would just be for
cameo if it is to be honest they'll be a
bit disappointed
but you know i think she'll actually
have a decent role possibly um she could
help demand
lauren deliver baby yoda back to his
homeland or
she might have some information
regarding something like that honestly i
don't know but you know please post your
own theories and predictions in the
comment section below
and it's also a rumor that we'll get
more marketing this month
before season two releases so i reckon
we'll actually get another trailer cause
you know for season one we got two
trailers and so far for season two
only one trailer so i'm gonna predict
something i reckon we're gonna get
another trailer for season two
and they're gonna showcase the socatano
at the end of the trailer
and that's really going to hype up the
release for season two
anyway guys that's about it for this
video so please post the comments below
let me know in the comment section below
if you think rissario dawson will play a
good asakitano and what role do you
think she'll play in season two
[Music]
you